[Music]
it is the best-selling book in history
no volume ever written has been more
loved and quoted
and its words sometimes simple and
sometimes mysterious
should always be studied carefully it
is the bible the word of god
welcome to bible answers live providing
accurate and practical answers to all
your bible questions
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode to receive any of the bible
resources mentioned in this broadcast
call 800-835-6747
once again that's 800-835-6747
now here's your host from amazing facts
international
pastor doug batchelor hello friends
would you like to hear an amazing fact
when helen viola jackson died december
16 2020
in a marshfield missouri nursing home
she was the last
civil war widow now the civil war was
over in 1865
that's 155 years ago so you might be
wondering how this is possible
well it came about when jackson was a 17
year old school girl
and her father asked if she could help
look after a neighbor a 93 year old
civil war veteran
named james brolin bolin had fought
during the union
fought for the union in the border state
of missouri
to repay her kindness bowlen offered to
marry jackson
which would allow her to receive his
soldiers pension after his death
this is a very tempting offer during the
great depression
with the help of a local pastor they wed
september 4
1936 at bolin's home throughout their
three years of marriage he continued
living at home and assures there was no
intimacy
after bolin's death in 1939 she never
applied for his pension
viola was too ashamed of the scandal of
a 17 year old marrying a man in his 90s
she never told her parents her siblings
or anyone else about the wedding
and she never remarried spending decades
harboring this secret
only in recent years she came forward
telling her pastor the truth
and the county and military records
confirmed her story
jackson also kept the bible that james
bolden gave her in which he wrote about
the marriage
so when viola jackson died december 2020
at 101 years of age
she was almost certainly the last
remaining widow
of a civil war soldier after bolin's
relatives found out about jackson's role
in his life
they went to the nursing home and
presented her with a framed photo of him
they said she broke down and cried and
kept stroking the frame
saying this was the only man who ever
loved me
friends you know the bible says there's
nothing that can separate us from the
love of god
stay with us we're going to learn more
on this edition of bible answers live
you're listening to bible answers live
accurate and practical answers to your
bible questions
welcome friends once again to bible
answers live and if you have a bible
question we are live and the phone lines
are
open and you can call with your question
the number is 800-463-7297
that's 800 god says brings your question
into the studio
and we also have another number we give
out for the free resources so you might
want to have
something to write with there's always
plenty of books we make available
for people to study out bible subjects
we are also streaming if you want to
watch what's happening here in the
studio online
and that's simply the doug batchelor
facebook page
or the amazing facts facebook page and i
think soon we're going to be streaming
on youtube live as well
and so we look forward to you having you
call in with our questions if you call
in you don't get picked up right away
just to let it ring a minute and our
operators will get to you
my name is doug batchelor my name is
john ross good evening friends
and past today as we always do let's
start with prayer dear father we thank
you that
once again we have this opportunity to
study a word and
we thank you that we can join in
wherever we might be as we search the
scriptures
we pray your holy spirit be with us here
in the studio and be with those who are
listening wherever they might be driving
their car at home whatever the case and
just ask your guidance in jesus name
amen amen well pastor you opened the
program telling a story about what's
quite remarkable
um sure enough the oldest remaining
widow of a civil war veteran died
last month it's incredible yeah talking
about people
getting married at old ages before the
program we were talking about
after the death of sarah abraham
remarried and
we did a little math a hundred and must
have been somewhere around 137
yes years of age yeah it tells us that
one of the few women in the bible where
it gives her age when she died is sarah
matter of fact she may be the only one
and sarah died at 127 she was 90
when abraham was 100 and they she gave
birth to isaac
after her death abraham uh still must
have had some zip in his hip and he
married again and had several other
children
so um anyway but this is an interesting
story
and she she was ashamed of it for years
but finally when
she told her pastor he said that's
remarkable that makes you one of the
last civil war
widow veteran widows and so uh
pretty soon everybody in her town sort
of made her a hero but
um you know it made me think about a
verse in the bible when
viola was saying that no one ever really
loved her
except this war veteran it reminded me
that
there's a lot of people go through life
and wonder does anyone really love me
you know she never married again and she
may have felt very isolated and alone as
many do right now
but i want you to know friends you are
not alone jesus has promised i'm with
you wherever you go
and you can read in romans 8 38 39
for i am persuaded paul says that
they're
neither life or death or angels or
principalities or powers or things
present or things that come
or height or depth or any other created
thing
is able to separate us from the love of
god which is in christ jesus
our lord do you know about that love
there's somebody who really does love
you
even though there's tribulation and
problems in the world this person loves
you so much they gave their
life that you might live if you choose
to believe
and follow him and we'd like to share a
book that tells you about
how you can experience that love and
that gift of everlasting life
you ever thought about it friends why
not now i think we're near to the second
coming of jesus
and it's a good idea to get to know him
now if you don't know him yet
we've got a free book called three steps
to heaven we'd like to make available
and that is available to anyone who
would like to call and ask
i just asked for the book it's called
three steps to heaven and the number to
call is 800-835-6747
that is the resource phone line ask the
book three steps to heaven we'll be
happy to send it to anyone in
north america if you're watching outside
of north america
we encourage you to go to the website
amazingfacts.org
and you can read it for free at the
website on our
library there but if you'd like a hard
copy we'll get in the mail to you this
week 800 835
670 is the resource phone line
gonna go to the phone lines we've got
anthony listening in new york anthony
welcome to the program
uh good evening pastors how are you
doing well thank you for calling
okay great um my question uh comes from
deuteronomy
uh chapter 18 verse 21 and 22. okay
um and it's basically uh i want to
expound on a little bit but
it's how do we distinguish between
a failed prophecy and a conditional one
and i asked this question because i i
see more and more
i belong to a denomination where we
believe in the gift of prophecy
was manifested in one of god's servants
and i hear a lot of people
you know speaking against it by saying
oh well the prophecy didn't come true
so that shows that she's a false prophet
but i believe that there were
conditional prophecies but i'm just not
sure how we can
show from the bible how to determine
which one is conditional and
when a prophecy is a failed prophecy
okay fair enough
you know and many people when they think
about conditional prophecies they think
well didn't jonah go into nineveh and
say 40 days in nineveh will be destroyed
that was clearly a conditional prophecy
they were going to be destroyed because
of their wickedness
but god is not willing that any should
perish and so when the city went through
a very intense repentance and they
turned away they fasted they prayed they
turned from their wickedness
god said well look i i'm gonna postpone
this judgment even wicked king ahab
elijah said that he was gonna you know
his uh dynasty was going to be destroyed
and when he got that word after killing
nabath
he humbled himself greatly and god says
because he's humbling himself i'm going
to postpone that judgment
and it didn't happen until after abra
ahab's death
and so you know god sometimes will
postpone
uh certain judgments that are given in a
prophecy if people
repent he never wants to just destroy
anyone
he'd always prefer that they repent even
daniel told nebuchadnezzar he said
how do i avert this judgment that i
dreamed about daniel said put away your
sins by righteousness and it'll be a
lengthening
of your tranquility so you know that's
one important aspect anthony and
and you know many prophets if a true
prophet makes a prophecy
you know it's like joshua said and
pastor ross i you might help me find
where
joshua said all that god has promised
has happened not one word has fallen to
the ground of all that god
the good word i think you might type in
fall under the ground or something
and he said everything that moses had
prophesied
happened now that was all the good
things about giving them the promised
land
moses also prophesied a lot of judgments
and they also happened
but they took hundreds of years he said
if you turn away from the lord
you're going to be carried off captive
you're going to be besieged by your
enemies and
all those things happen i don't know if
you run onto that one still working on
that one yeah okay
anyway um but um i i think it might be
when uh
joshua he also says um
as for me and my house we will serve the
lord it's i think just before after that
but uh hope that helps a little bit
anthony and um
and then of course in deuteronomy it
says if a prophet makes a prophecy
and it doesn't come true in most cases
it means they're a false prophet
right man we do have that study guide
that talks about that it's called
doesn't
does god inspire psychics and
astrologers
and we'll be happy to send that to
anyone wanting to learn more about what
does the bible say about the gift of
prophecy is it still relevant today
if you'd like to receive that study
guide the number is 800-835-6747
and ask for the study guide it's study
guide uh
i don't know the exact number but ask
for it it says does god inspire
astrologists and psychics that's the
name of the study guide and we'll be
happy to send that out to anyone who
asks
we've got george listening from new
jersey george welcome to the program
uh good evening pastors how you doing
tonight doing well thanks for calling
uh uh by the way pastor doug i've been
watching you on the ion network that
you're now
on so just oh that's right first of the
year we're on now praise the lord
just went on earlier this morning yep ah
the question i have uh tonight uh last
week i i didn't call but i heard you
talking about the transfiguration last
last week and you said that moses was
resurrected to be part of that which i
tend to believe believing in conditional
immortality
the only thing i have a problem with in
trying to reconcile that with christ is
the first fruits
of those who slept you see what i'm
saying
which is i guess in corinthians or
someplace and plus we have enoch and
elijah of course they didn't die they
were
translated i guess how would you
reconcile that
that statement christ is the first
fruits when of course moses was already
resurrected
you know while christ was living yeah
well when
when you took a first fruit from the
harvest you didn't take
one piece of grain you usually took a
bundle and so
christ would still qualify as first
fruit if technically moses was still
resurrected
so uh you know you can't look at a lot
of people that were resurrected you
think about
in the great resurrection at the second
coming when the dead in christ rise
you're looking at millions of people and
so compared to the millions that will be
resurrected
and even the you know the group of
people that were resurrected at the
resurrection of christ there was a
smaller group
says many of those that slept in the
graves when there's this earthquake
the graves opened and they arose from
their graves and appeared to
many in the city and that's only in the
gospel of matthew
but even that's another a bigger group
but compared to those
groups you know jesus and maybe moses
before him
he said jesus still qualifies as the
first fruit and i think also the first
the first fruit is not necessarily
sequential yes
not numerical value is in one two three
but rather imposition
and authority importance so and
important so it's through christ's
resurrection that any others can hope to
be resurrected
well that's what i was thinking like he
was the chief one or the
head one you know yeah or others
followed him when you call the
president's wife the first lady you
don't mean she was the first lady in the
u.s
you mean that she's a first in standing
as far as you know
a position of dignity so a good point
that helps a lot thank you all right
thank you george appreciate your call
we've got marie listening in canada
marie welcome to the program
hi yes good evening to both of you
pastors uh
bachelor and ross thank you very much
for taking my call
thank you uh and i hope you understand
my strong french accent
you're from a french part of canada i am
yes that's all right we'll do our best
but uh yeah how can we help you tonight
that's fine if i stick too fast please
let me know i have a quick question
uh it's concerning actually um
the chapter number sorry
a book of numbers chapter 12 yes
and that will be it starts actually with
uh
verse one when aaron and
miriam are criticizing our looking down
on moses wife
and in verse 10 uh god's
being upset actually miriam
she's she has leprosy and she's becoming
white as snow
now my question is and i'm i hope
actually uh
you know i'm not going to confuse you
with that
i was thinking of racism so of course
with what's been happening last
summer in the us and we're trying to
actually
you know um riots against racism we know
that
even the state of prophecy was against
it she denounced it and that's why she
was kind of banished to australia
and my question is um
with that text of number
can we actually say can can we safely
say that god is really upset
when actually you have this action of
racism for him
just to make sure that miriam had
leprosy and being white as snow
can we say that please well all right
let's talk about
that marie that's a great question uh
first of all just to give our listeners
a background uh miriam's asking about
numbers 12 and the story here
is moses was the youngest of the three
siblings
aaron mary and moses it's almost like a
god used this trinity
one of them was a spiritual prophetess
and then you had aaron the older brother
and then you have moses and
they helped that family help lead the
people out
but moses had married the bible says he
had married an ethiopian
now we don't know if it's talking about
zipporah who is a midianite but the
midianites
they that may have been considered part
ethiopian but they were definitely
entertaining some prejudice against
against zipporah or moses wife
and um and they were punished for that
so i think it is a statement that's
being made
that god is no respecter of persons
and the bible tells us that god has made
all nations of one blood
and that you know when people express
that kind of discrimination
god is not pleased he not only judged
miriam he later forgave mary and she had
leprosy but he healed her
but jesus also told the jewish nation
even the old his own apostles were often
prejudiced
looking upon gentiles as dogs
and jesus said you know many are going
to come from the east and west and sit
down in the kingdom with abraham isaac
and jacob
and some of the natural children are
going to be in outer darkness
just like miriam was cast out of the
camp because of her leprosy
so i think that the lord is telling us
there that um
he does not uh approve of or you know
racism
or that kind of prejudice or
discrimination now the bible tells us
that
god is not a respecter of persons the
man looks at the outward god looks at
the heart
so uh i think as christians as followers
of christ
you know even even in the time of jesus
there was definitely a lot of hostility
and racism between the jews and the
samaritans and
the greeks and the romans and we find
jesus ministering to
all groups of people the woman at the
well samaritan woman where he
he spoke to her and gave her hope and
life
and so christ is the example this is the
example of
we're all brothers and sisters in him
and yes
all right well thank you marie that's
that's a good point you brought up there
we've got donna in missouri donna
welcome to the program
donna you may have your mute on are you
there
uh i i'm donna but i'm in montana oh
okay sorry
i have the wrong abbreviation yeah
okay good evening pastors um my question
my question is this um after jesus was
resurrected
he saw mary magdalene and he told her
not to touch him because he had not yet
ascended to his father
yes but then uh they i guess it was days
later
he was with the disciples uh again
and thomas who had doubted that it was
jesus
jesus said to thomas thrust your
hand into my side so why did he tell
mary not to touch him
but thomas could touch him yeah that's
i'm glad you asked that question because
it's often misunderstood and if you read
it in the king
james version in the old english when
jesus said do not
do not touch me the word there in greek
means
cling to me he was getting ready to
ascend to heaven and mary when she saw
him she fell at his feet and maybe
reached out to grab his feet
and he said mary do not detain me a
matter of fact i think some translations
word it that way pastor ross in john
chapter eight
do not uh rather john 20 do not detain
me
for i have not yet ascended because
after jesus ascends to heaven comes back
down
he sees the disciples and he says all
hail
and they worship him so he didn't want
mary to be so excited that she was
clinging to him that he could not ascend
and have his sacrifice declared
victorious and successful
then he came back of course that sunday
evening and he met with uh
met with several that of the disciples
actually
so he wasn't telling mary don't touch me
he was saying don't cling to me
does that help a little bit yes
i read i read the king james so that's
yeah that's i
i understand that now yeah i asked the
same question when i first encountered
that as that doesn't sound like jesus
don't touch me because jesus was always
very good about letting people
come and he jesus would even you know
reach out and touch lepers
so thank you so much appreciate that and
um
i was just thinking you know we have uh
we've got that book
um there's a book called at jesus
feet and you could probably contact
amazing facts and i think they've got a
very inexpensive sharing version of that
book
about mary magdalene and her encounter
with jesus
all right thanks for your call donna we
got kate listening in brooklyn new york
kate welcome to the program
hello hi you're on how are you
oh hi um hi pastor doug
and pastor thank you for your time
my question is about people who lived
before jesus christ
and they did not know the salvation of
jesus christ's blood and
how are they going to be saved is it by
their good deeds and sacrifices like in
old days
thank you so much good question kate
thank you um
nobody is going to be saved because of
their good works
um because you know everyone is saved by
the grace of
god there may be some i expect there
will be
who maybe were born before the time of
christ or they were born in countries
that never heard about jesus and i think
in romans 1
and another place is it says that um you
know
god looks on the hearts of people and
there there are people who are
barbarians that maybe didn't even know
about god but god's law was written in
their heart
and they walked in all the light they
had
and in acts it says that
he that does good in every nation god is
accepted by god
so you know the lord i think is going to
extend his grace and mercy to people
that had no opportunity to hear the
gospel
but they walked in all the light that
the holy spirit and maybe angels
communicated to them
and we'll be surprised to see some
people in the kingdom
that are just there by god's intervene
intervening
but as you mentioned everyone is saved
through the sacrifice of christ
those before the cross look forward in
faith we get to look back
in faith yep all right thank you for
your call we've got uh let's see i
believe tony's next in texas tony
welcome to the program
good evening both pastors how are you
doing well
thank you for calling good good good
good my question
uh my wife's been bugging me and i don't
have an answer so i said well i'll call
you guys could you have an answer
uh is there any scriptures
in the bible or does the bible talk at
all about jesus smiling
and or laughing you know they're they're
they're pretty uh
they're pretty uh detailed about
everything of his life but we don't
see anything in there about him smiling
and or laughing
well good question you know there's more
examples in the old testament where it
talks about
god laughing sometimes it says god
laughs at their calamity meaning that
you know
people but um one example i can think i
can point you to
that's it's sort of circumstantial but i
think it still makes the point
if you go to luke 24 when jesus rises
from the dead he appears to two
disciples
on the road to emmaus if you start in
verse
yeah you go to verse 17 and jesus said
what kind of conversation is this that
you have with one another
as you walk and are sad he's really
criticizing the disciples for having a
sad walk
i think jesus said the gospel is good
news
and he always was telling the disciples
when they were afraid he said do not be
afraid
and he says rejoice so
the word rejoice contains the word joy
and you know i don't think and you know
jesus had struggles and suffering in his
life no doubt
uh sometimes it calls him a man of
sorrows and acquainted with grief
but he also uh children were attracted
to him
and i think that he he was a person who
smiled a lot
and they were you know aware that he was
a joyful person
yeah i thought i thought maybe like um
when uh when when they came and told him
that lazarus was dead and he kind of
said
he's just sleeping don't worry about it
i it seemed like he might have said that
in a
you know in a laughing or a smiling way
and then he went to
you know to raise him but it's not
specifically said that but i didn't see
something
then you have pardon me you have the
places where jesus does actually
incorporate some humor in his teaching
when he talks about
now if you've got a a friend and he's
got a speck of sawdust in his eye
and you've got a log he really uses that
word you've got a log
like a piece of firewood in your eye you
might want to first take the firewood
out of your eye before you get the speck
out of your brother's eye or when jesus
talks about a camel going through the
eye of a needle that's you know pretty
that's hyperbole it's a pretty
outrageous example
so jesus incorporated i think some
humor in his teachings as well
and i think that he certainly did smile
but you know you don't find a specific
verse that said jesus smiled
but he does talk a lot about rejoicing
thank you very much tony hope that helps
some
we've got joel listening in north
carolina joel welcome to the program
hi pastor doug hi pastor ross hi
my question is uh my question is
about genesis 15 17.
um i was wondering is the
the the oven and the torch
is that god the father and then the
torches
is the glory that we can't we can't be
around
his glory yeah this is telling about
when god made a covenant with
abraham in genesis 15 and it says that
as the sun went down
and it was dark behold there appeared a
smoking oven and a burning torch that
passed between those
pieces the bible talks about the
shekinah
glory the glory of god like a burning
fire that
entered the temple both in the days of
moses and in the days of solomon and
even david
and i think that this may have been an
example of the glory of god that
was confirming the covenant by having
his presence or his
shekinah pass between the pieces of
sacrifice
and so you know whether it's the father
of the son i would think it's probably
god the son
because the bible says no man has seen
the father at any time any thoughts
pastor ross on that
yeah i think it's just a further
explanation it talks about a smoking
oven and a burning torch
i don't think they're two necessarily
two separate
beings but rather description of this
glorious presence that came and passed
through
great significance to that by the way
where christ is making a covenant god's
making a covenant with abraham
and um yeah that covenant was true
through abraham the messiah came and
then of course the the
hebrews say that that burning smoke and
furnace
was a reminder of the furnace of
persecution that nation was going to go
through
the descendants of abraham were going to
go through hey thank you very much
i hope that helps a little bit joel and
we
are coming up on our mid-time break and
we have more bible questions lined up we
see you waiting
and anthony and ivan orion and damon
we're going to be back in just a moment
stay with us we'll get to your questions
stay tuned bible answers live will
return shortly
[Music]
in six days god created the heavens and
the earth
for thousands of years man has
worshipped god on the seventh day of the
week
now each week millions of people worship
on the first day
what happened why did god create a day
of rest
does it really matter what day we
worship who is behind this great shift
discover the truth behind god's law and
how it was changed
visit sabbathtruth.com
for life-changing christian resources
visit afbookstore.com
did you know that noah was present at
the birth of abraham
okay maybe he wasn't in the room but he
was alive and probably telling stories
about his floating zoo
from the creation of the world to the
last day events of revelation
biblehistory.com is a free resource
where you can explore major bible events
and characters
enhance your knowledge of the bible and
draw closer to god's word
go deeper visit biblehistory.com
what if you could know the future
what would you do what would you change
to see the future you must understand
the past
alexander the great becomes king when
he's only 18 but he's a
military prodigy 150 years in advance
cyrus had been named rome was
violent they were ruthless they were
determined
the gospel writers see his death as
a fulfillment of salvation this
intriguing documentary hosted by pastor
doug batchelor
explores the most striking bible
prophecies that have been dramatically
fulfilled throughout history
kingdoms in time get your copy today
available now on dvd blu-ray or usb
for more information visit
kingdomsandtime.com
[Music]
you're listening to bible answers live
where every question answered provides a
clearer picture of god
and his plan to save you so what are you
waiting for
get practical answers about the good
book for a better life
today
if you have a question about the bible
or living the christian life
call us now at 800 god says
that's 800-463-7297
now let's rejoin our hosts for more
bible answers live welcome back
listening friends two bible answers live
if you tuned in somewhere in route
this is a bible answer program where we
invite people to call in from all over
the country in the world
with their bible questions and that
number again is 800-463-7297
and you can also watch and i think even
text in your questions
going to the facebook doug batchelor
facebook page or the amazing facts
facebook page
and i am doug batchelor my name is john
ross and again we
want to go to the phone lines we've got
damon listening from
oklahoma city damon welcome to the
program
hey how you doing doing good
oh great great um i had i need a better
understanding of a bible verse
um revelation 12 um
chapter 14 17 this
kind of confused on what he's talking
about all right so revelation 12 verses
14 to 17.
yes sir let me read this for our friends
that are listening
but to the woman was given two wings of
an eagle that she might fly into the
wilderness
to her place where she is nourished for
a time and at times and half a time
from the presence of the serpent so the
serpent spewed out water out of his
mouth like a flood after the woman that
he might
cause her to be carried away by the
flood but the earth helped the woman
and the earth opened its mouth and
swallowed the flood that the dragon had
spewed out of his mouth
and the dragon was enraged with a woman
and he went to make war with the rest of
her
offspring who keep the commandments of
god and have the testimony of jesus
christ
now this is a this is a good sermon
right here i mean a good 45
or 15 minute sermon but i'll do my best
to give you a quick
truncated answer here the serpent is the
devil
the woman here is the church the true
church
you find her in the first few verses
standing on the moon
clothed with the sun crowned with the
stars
these are the lights that god made god
said to the church you are the light of
the world
the devil's trying to put out her light
and destroy her she brings forth the
man-child she introduces the man-child
to the world and that's christ and
after the man-child is caught up to
god's throne that jesus is no longer
within the devil's reach
the devil tries to destroy the woman and
after jesus ascended to heaven
there was a great persecution that was
turned against the church
and the church went underground uh you
know they built catacombs in rome and
throughout europe and they fled into the
mountains and it tells us that there was
a period of time for
it says for a time of times and half a
time that's a time period you hear
mentioned
several times in the bible in in daniel
and in revelation talks about three and
a half years
42 months which is also three and a half
jewish years 30 days to the month and it
also calls it a time
meaning one complete year a times or a
couple a pair
that's two more so one season plus two
seasons is three
and a dividing of a time half a year
three and a half
so you've got this time period keeps
coming up
in the old testament there the church
was persecuted elijah fled into the
wilderness and god fed him there
for three and a half years the prophets
were hidden in caves they went
underground
and god preserved the truth then in new
testament times
there was a period from 538
to 1798 1260 years
of persecution from the government
church
during the dark ages and the
woman fled into the wilderness and god
protected her there
and he continued to feed her with the
word of god
but in the last days the dragon is going
to turn his fury once more on the church
and make war
this is the final battle of armageddon
when the dragon makes war on the woman
now i know i i give you a lot don't we
have a lesson we can offer on this year
i'm just looking at one that i think the
light of christ
yeah the bride of christ is a good one
and also the one
right on time that i think also deals
with some of the time prophecies and
again this would be great for anyone
wanting to learn more about revelation
um you can just call and ask for it the
number to call is 800-835-6747
ask for the study guide is called right
on time and
the bride of christ both of these two
study guides deal with revelation
chapter 12
and give you a lot more information
especially the one the bride of christ i
think you'll really enjoy that
thank you for your call damon we got uh
orion
listening from california is it orion
orion sir yes welcome
good evening thank you for your ministry
i thank god for your ministry
i really thank you i'm really blessed
with your ministry
my question is in regards to mark 13
32 would you like me to read it
go ahead okay i'm reading from an iv
version but about
the day and the hour no one knows not
even the angels in heaven
nor the son but only the father now
since we don't know the
days and the hour would it be possible
for us to know the year
and if it's possible for us to know the
year
uh when will it be
what you will be all right thank you so
much orion i appreciate that
yeah jesus not only says in mark chapter
13 he says in matthew 24 that day in the
hour knows
no one not even the angels but my father
only and in luke
he says you know you want to look at the
signs of the
times so we should keep our heads
looking up so we
know when the time is near so i think
god you know gives us plenty of signs
in matthew 24 mark 13 luke 21
that tell us when the time is near but i
think we ought to guard against picking
a day or an hour or even a year you know
because
um there have been a lot of people who
have picked
the year of jesus coming many times in
history
going back probably over a thousand
years people have been picking dates
and you know what so far they've all
been wrong and uh
the people then get all excited and then
they get discouraged you know they get
excited like
like a caffeinated drink and then they
end up getting the depression afterward
when
they crash and they lose faith so i
think we ought to avoid
picking a date the key for a christian
is not to just know what the date is
it's to be ready
to live in a state of readiness because
christ could come for you
whoever you are listening wherever you
are you don't know if you have another
day of life and when you
when your earthly probation is over
whether you have a heart attack
you get hit by a meteor or you die from
sickness
your next conscious thought is the
resurrection and the judgment day so we
want to live
in an attitude of being ready for jesus
coming
you know we do have a study guide
talking about the second coming of
christ
and it says it's entitled anything but
secret talking about how jesus will come
and also highlight some of the
the signs that the bible gives uh and
we'll be happy to send this to you orion
or anyone wanting to learn more
the number is 800-835-6747
asks for the book it's called anything
but secret it's all about the second
coming of christ
we've got colton listening in ohio
colton welcome to the program
hi hi colton how are you
good um my question
is what was jesus like
when he was a little boy well it's
interesting you're asking that question
i'm writing a book
right now called when jesus was a little
child
and i'm i'm studying that but i'm sure
he was like
other little boys in that he probably
loved
animals and i expect that he he you know
ran
in the grass they rolled in the grass
and he swung from the trees he probably
tried to help his father in the
carpenter shop
and his dad maybe made him a little
wagon or a cart he could pull around the
town of nazareth and
he probably had a pet puppy or he liked
some of the animals in town i think
jesus was a normal
little boy but he was good he always
listened to his parents he never told a
lie
he probably was always helpful for his
neighbors
um i'll try and get you one of those
books when they're done it's not quite
ready
okay thank you thank you colton
appreciate your call
all right we always like to hear from
the young people calling yeah
um you know pastor day just wrapping
that one off i thought one verse where
it says jesus grew in favor with god and
man
so he had a very pleasant disposition he
was helpful as you mentioned
he was known in the village as being a
helping positive influence and
um yeah the bible says that i think it's
where
mary and joseph lost track of him and
says he went home and he was subject to
them
so he was an obedient son right right
yeah all right we got hannah listening
in texas hannah welcome to the program
hi thank you hi
um my question comes from john chapter
six
um it says no one can come to me unless
the father who sent me draws him
and then again it says later that
therefore i have said unto you that no
one could come to me unless it has been
granted to him by my father
but does that mean that some people
can't be saved because god didn't choose
them or
well i think that it also tells us in
the bible god is not willing that any
should perish
and jesus you know in john 3 16 he says
whosoever believeth in him
but i think that god sends the spirit to
work in people's hearts and to strive
with him and so jesus is saying
if you have an interest in me it's
because the father wants you to be saved
and he's sending the spirit to strive in
your heart
i don't think christ was denying that
some
that he wants some to be saved i think
he was saying everyone that is saved
it's because of god's pursuing them and
they're responding to that pursuit
yeah and that's that's available to
anyone as mentioned god's not willing
that any should perish so the holy
spirit is speaking to the hearts of all
how we respond to that determines
whether or not we are saved if we come
to jesus if we respond to the prompting
so
the father is drawing jesus said if i am
lifted up i shall draw all men unto
myself so
the spirit is constantly working upon
the hearts of men and women
so that doesn't mean then that god
arbitrarily chooses who's going to be
saved and who's going to be lost and you
have nothing
to say in the matter yeah and then i
think paul tells us in
is that first timothy god who would have
all men to be saved
and so he wants everyone to be saved god
is not willing that any should perish
and it's like joshua said who who is on
the lord's side or choose you this day
who you will serve you know we have a
book hannah that i think you'll enjoy
reading it's called can a save man
choose to be lost and we'll send this to
anyone who calls and asks the number
again for our resource
phone line is 800 835
and you can ask for the book it's called
can a saved man choose to be lost
we got emanuel from africa from ghana
africa emmanuel
you're on the air hello good morning
and for the dog hello hi
sorry your question yeah you broke up on
us you have to say that again
how are you doing oh we're doing good
thank you
thank you please my person this morning
in uh genesis chapter 15 verse 9
to the abraham to to make a sacrifice
with uh some animals yes a 30 dove and
then
a heifer so i'm asking that is animal
sacrifice
important in this last days
i mean i want to understand if any my
sacrifice is
necessary for christians all right well
thank you very much
and um you know i would say no because
and you can read in is it first
corinthians where paul says that christ
is our passover that is sacrificed for
us
and when jesus died the veil in the
curtain the
veil in the temple was torn from top to
bottom
indicating the end of the sacrificial
system he was the lamb of god that took
away the sin of the world
there's no purpose to shed animals blood
anymore yeah and of course we have the
verse in romanship
12 1 it says this is a great verse i
beseech you therefore brethren by the
mercies of god that you present your
bodies as a living sacrifice
wholly acceptable to god which is your
reasonable service
so is there a sacrifice in new testament
yes it is
a sacrifice of ourselves we are
surrendering ourselves to christ
of course jesus is the lamb of god that
takes away the sins of the world so you
can't add to that
christ meant that fulfillment when he
died on the cross there's no need for
animal sacrifices
and i'm sure grateful for that yeah and
i think even david says in psalm 51 the
sacrifices of god are a contrite spirit
a humble and a contrite spirit so even
in the old testament
you know malachi says what shall i give
to the lord shall i offer thousands of
rams and and blood and he said here's
what god wants
do justly love mercy walk humbly with
god
he's not wanting dead animals he wants
our hearts
the sacrificial system was all pointing
to jesus
not necessary now to sacrifice thank you
for your call next call we have is
barry listening in uh south carolina
barry welcome to the program
hello there thank you pastors for taking
my call i i never really get to listen
to you live
uh i'll hear recorded verses on wbaj
here in our area
but uh opportunity and uh but with
revelation chapter five verses one
through seven we have
uh john uh who's sad because in verse
three it says that there's no one in
heaven or on earth or under the earth
able to open the scroll and look upon it
and
i always try to look for parallels that
kind of help explain stuff or time
things whether it's a prophecy or
something like that
and a previous caller had had john 20
and 17
where jesus had told mary not to detain
him right and at that particular point
in time
jesus was not in heaven he was not on
the earth as a man because he had a
regenerated new body
and he was not dead in the grave could
that have satisfied that criteria here
in revelation chapter five
oh i see what you're saying that would
have been a window in time where no one
was available to open the book
because christ was sort of in the middle
of transition
right and then in verse six and seven
when he takes the scroll
that would have been him leaving mary
and going to heaven perhaps
yeah i i think that primarily in
revelation 5 there it's just saying that
there's this great anticipation that the
scroll should be opened and you know
assuming this is the book of life and no
one really had the right
to open that book except the one who
gave his blood to
pay the penalty and that was it's the
lamb who is slain that we see figured
there
what do you think pastor ross yeah
absolutely you know revelation chapter 4
you have a description of the heavenly
throne room and everyone's there the
father's there the 24 elders the four
living creatures
except the lamb except christ jesus then
appears in chapter five so it's almost
as if the stage is set in chapter four
and everyone's waiting for christ this
is after his ascension
and then jesus enters in and he takes
the scroll and he's worthy to open the
seals
and uh yeah to parallel that with um
john chapter 20
where jesus is resurrected and he's
talking to mary magdalene at the tomb
i think the time frame is right on that
occurred just before
we find uh revelation chapter five where
jesus appears
interesting well you made us think
tonight barry we sure appreciate that
and
yeah keep listening there i've been to
uh
north carolina i met a lot of the
listeners to uh wbj
c i forget what the the call says north
carolina that was yeah
that was um the station i think was in
north carolina but it's also occurred in
south carolina
all right well thank you barry we going
to go to joe in connecticut joe welcome
to the program
thank you for taking my call pastors
good evening
evening i have a question regarding
boris um my
church teaches that if a husband or a
wife
commits adultery then divorce is allowed
by the bible
however doesn't the bible teach that
if we break one of the ten commandments
we have broken them all so for instance
if a wife or a husband breaks the
sabbath commandment or breaks one of the
other commandments
according to james 2 10-11
they have committed adultery and so
if both those things are true then my
understanding is that the
pharisees were correct and jesus was
wrong
well i think if you take james the way
you're interpreting it there that would
be
extreme that would be like sayings
because you break one commandment you're
guilty of all
and so if you know if a person
tells a lie which is a sin he's just as
guilty as a person who commits murder
and the bible doesn't teach that there
are varying degrees
of sin and there are different penalties
for different sins
so you know god i think is pretty clear
that
marriage is sacred and people should not
be
violating the marriage vows now if a
couple
if there's been infidelity in a marriage
jesus doesn't say they have to get
divorced
jesus said this would be the only
biblical grounds for divorce
and so um now i don't know is that does
that make sense
uh joe are you still with me
uh to me that doesn't make sense at all
you said jesus said uh
you said something that jesus said but
my bible says
jesus said that let not
man put asunder and he said whosoever
whosoever puts away his wife
and marries another commits adultery
against her
i don't see any have you read where
no i know but it it does say in matthew
chapter 5
and in matthew 19 the disciples said is
there any grounds for divorce
and he said saving for the cause of
fornication
now actually um up until the time of
christ
the jews had some rabbinical laws that
they they could divorce their wife for
bad cooking and uh you know jesus was
saying
you know yeah moses gave you permission
to divorce because of the hardness of
your hearts but from the beginning it
was not so
but um the verse you're referring to
pasadena is matthew chapter 5
32 where it specifically mentions there
except for
um fornication yeah so you know i i have
a book i'd like to send you a free copy
joe if you'd like it it's called
marriage divorce and remarriage and it
covers this from the bible perspective
and it took a lot of time thinking
through the bible teachings and looking
at some
some other good commentaries on this i
think you'll find it helpful
anyone out there if you're wondering
what does the bible say about marriage
divorce and remarriage
and also some principles to having a
happy and
uh not to endure marriage but to enjoy
your marriage the number to call is
five six seven four seven that is the
resource phone line as to the book
called marriage divorce and
remarriage and we'll send it out to you
we've got uh
jeff listening from iowa jeff welcome to
the program
hi good evening thank you pastor ross
and
pastor batcher yeah hi jeff
hello how can we help you tonight my
question and it's it's hard for me it's
confusing to me and when i'm asked i
have a hard time
it relates to daniel for a chapter 12
verses 11 and 12.
more specifically how do
how do the uh time frames
1290 days and 1335 days
relate to the 2300 day prophecy
uh and the twelve twelve hundred and
sixty days within that
oh man you've asked a big question it's
kind of like you know
a light just said to elisha you've asked
a hard thing
[Laughter]
the the daniel 12 has more time
prophecies in it in those few verses
there than any other place in the bible
you've got a 1260 and you've got the
1290 and the 1335.
i think the key to understanding those
prophecies in daniel 12
it's sort of a summary of a a great
battle
between good and evil that you see
happening in other
chapters chapter 2 talks about these
kingdoms
chapter 7 talks about the prophecy of
the four animals chapter eight it's the
goat in the ram covering the same
battle between the antichrist little
horn power
and then you find the little horn also
in chapter seven
chapter eight then it gives it more
detail in chapter
nine when the messiah comes chapter 10
11 and 12 is sort of one long
prophecy and just maybe to get uh you
know i think we're all familiar with the
1260 at least we've heard of that one
that's
the dark ages from 538 till 1798.
the 1290 would begin in
the date that's been put forward is 508
which was the conversion of clovis king
of the franks now we might think well
that's not that big of a
big deal but that was rather significant
because he was pagan before that
he was converted to christianity and in
essence the entire nation of french
france became supporters of the papal
power which was necessary
to establish full sovereignty which
occurred
in 538 so that's that's the 1290 so
starting in 508 it brings you to 1798
when the papal power receives a deadly
wound and then the 1335
starting also in that same time period
five or eight it brings you up to 1843
when we have people preaching and
teaching and proclaiming
the prophecies of daniel in particular
the 2300 days
second coming it's the last age of the
church it's sure to leo to see it begins
about then also
right right so that's just a quick
summary of that and uh i'm just thinking
past the deck do we have a book we're
not just thinking we need a book
because we get that question and yeah
it's you really need to give a book it's
um
it's too deep to cover and through some
great articles on that subject and it's
it's very good
it's well hope that didn't just compound
confusion jeff we appreciate your call
we're going to see if we can squeeze in
one more question or before we run out
of our allotted time we've got
yolanda in arizona yolanda welcome to
the program
hi hi thank you yolanda we got about two
minutes can we do it
yeah yeah i'll talk faster okay
okay so my question uh okay uh my
question comes from genesis
chapter 19 verse 8 with the lot and his
daughters where it says i have two
daughters
which have not known man let me i pray
you
bring them out unto you and do you to
them
as is good in your eyes only until these
men do nothing for therefore can they
under the shadow of my roof
i just have a problem with a lot
offering his two daughters that way yeah
i don't blame you uh i've got two
daughters
the um and not only here but you'll find
that
the same thing happens in the end of the
book of judges where this
um this uh ephromite priest
levite he he said that when the men of
gibeah surround the house he says look
we'll send out
our wives but don't do this for one
thing it talks about
you know how god feels about um
that kind of sexual activity where
they're going to rape the men
the other thing is when someone came
under your roof in bible times
you were supposed to lay down your life
and everything you had to protect them
it was called sanctuary
they had very strong rules about
hospitality that's why they don't
go into lot's house they say send them
out
and i also think a lot was kind of
thinking i'll all off you my daughters
he was saying thinking they'd be ashamed
to even ask such a thing
that that would basically make them
ashamed and walk away
but it's not what they wanted and yeah
same thing that happened in the the
story in judges
and they just had very strong
scruples about the the teaching of
sanctuary someone came under your roof
for protection
you would do everything you could to
watch over them
so i know it is a difficult that's a
difficult passage
in in our thinking the way we are today
and um a lot of course his daughters
didn't have the best influence there
in sodom because they later seduced
their own father
anyway friends what a note to end on but
hey
call us next week we're going to get
into more bible study you can hear about
out of time
go to amazingfacts.org and keep us going
god bless friends
[Music]
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast we hope you understand your
bible
even better than before bible answers
live is produced by amazing facts
international
a faith-based ministry located in
granite bay
california
an international pandemic killing
thousands
riots ripping communities apart a global
economic implosion many are wondering
is this the end of the world few
question the military
economic and technological might of the
united states
so if we really are facing the last days
if these worldwide catastrophes are
really harbingers of the end
shouldn't we expect the united states to
play a key role
in the final events of bible prophecy
the book of revelation provides
unmistakable clues and to help you
understand them
amazing facts is releasing america in
bible prophecy
it's going to take you step by step in
identifying the global forces at work
in these last days you might be
surprised what the bible really says
you owe it to yourself to find out so
get yourself a copy
of america in bible prophecy for
life-changing christian resources visit
afbookstore.com
would you like to know god's plan for
our troubled world and solutions for
your life's challenges
beautifully redesigned and updated
amazing facts 27 bible study guides
provide straightforward bible-based
answers that are enlightening
encouraging and easy to understand
giving you real relevant bible answers
to questions like
how can i have healthier relationships
when will jesus come
and much more order yours today by
visiting afbookstore.com
or by calling 800-538-7275
did you know amazing facts has a free
bible school that you can do from the
comfort of your own home
it includes 27 beautifully illustrated
study lessons to aid in your study of
god's word
sign up today for this free bible study
course by calling
thousand 1-844-215-7000 one eight four
four two one five seven
thousand
[Music]
if you'd like to enhance your study of
god's word visit our website at w
dot and sign up for our free bible study
course
and make sure to check out our online
bookstore at afbookstore.com
which offers thousands of inspiring
books dvds and more
to help you get the most out of god's
word to take advantage of the offers
you've heard on this broadcast
call us at 800-835-6747
or visit our website at amazingfacts.org
[Music]